chance of russia russia filled the air
as thousands of people gathered Forellis
on the streets of the crimean capital
simferopol there is no doubt about which
way these people will vote in next
Sunday's referendum on leaving ukraine
around sixty percent of crimeans are
ethnic russians identifying with the
culture language and traditions of their
eastern neighbors many believe their
lives will improve if they join Russia
Crimea will be better off with Russia
economically as well as politically
Russia means stability he's cheap
energies and jobs that's why Crimea
wants to be part of Russia green where I
see it mr. poppy field Russian President
Putin has made it clear he supports
crimea's bid to leave Ukraine
but not all crimeans welcome that at a
much smaller pro-ukrainian rally
demonstrators urged those wanting to
maintain ties with Kiev to make their
voices heard it's an uphill battle we
need to speak out in the run-up to the
referendum otherwise there's no way back
once we're part of Russia it'll be too
late that's why as many people as
possible need to come out to protest now
so he's young closet addressing a rally
in Kiev to commemorate Ukrainian poet
and nationalists Tara's Shevchenko Prime
Minister Arseny Yatsenyuk vowed not to
give out Crimea this is our country our
fathers and grandfathers have spilt
their blunt for this country and we
won't give up a single centimeter of
Ukrainian land let Russia and its
president know this diplomatic efforts
to find a solution to the crisis have
also been intensifying Yatsenyuk is due
to meet us president barack obama for
talks in Washington next week